i want to share with you some massive
news today um
we have had a decision on the clay
crosstown deal and it is brilliant news
we are receiving 24 million pounds worth
of funding
to improve and regenerate clay costs
over the next
few years this is fantastic for our
local area and i'm so grateful for
everybody in the community
all the businesses everybody that's on
the board and to northeast irish
district council
for working together over the last year
so we can put this bid into government
and for the government listening to us
and coming forward with the opportunity
for us to be able to make play across
even better this is fantastic news
for clay cross huge news for northeast
derbyshire
in general we've got so much work to do
but this is brilliant we've got the
opportunity
to regenerate the town centre to improve
infrastructure
to improve the skills with people in
clay cross to make some absolutely
transformative changes i am so looking
forward to getting going today
is a really good day